Det känns som en motsättning här i att du har den här revisor, personligheten och den kreativa sidan.
Jag vet inte hur kreativ jag är men...
Energisk då.
Min tanke är att revisorer ska vara sura.
Hahaha Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobig generation och jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dessbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta men...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Ella från Smarta Saker till Podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Tjena, tjena.
Hej, kul att vara här.
Ja, tjena.
Kul att ha dig här.
Jag är lite fascinerad av ditt område här så jag tänker att vi hoppar in ganska fort så där.
Men kan du inte bara...
Man hör ju på namnet vad ni gör.
Men om man nu inte fattar vad ni gör, vad gör ni?
Vi har samlat ett sortiment av smarta och innovativa prylar som gör att vardagen och hemmet och livet och fritiden blir lite enklare.
Lite härligare.
Så det är grejer som har en smart innovation, en smart lösning som är den röda tråden.
Och ett stort fokus är vårt samarbete med svenska innovatörer och uppfinnare.
Det vill jag hamna lite grann i sen också, för det tycker jag inte att det har belysts så mycket i andra poddar som det har varit med i.
Så jag är väldigt intresserad av hur det samarbetet funkar.
Men jag tänker att smarta saker, det känns som den ultimata julklappshemsidan eller presenthemsidan.
Är det det som är era nisch eller går folk in där även i vanliga fall?
Nej men vi har väl flera som tror inte bara det.
Nästan 30% av omsättningen ligger i november-december.
Så det är ju ett absolut present destination.
Men i övrigt så är det ju resten av året en plats för folk som tycker att de organiserar sitt hem och som vill göra städning och tvätt lite roligare eller som fixar i köket.
Men också de här prylanthusiasterna som gillar att ha den senaste grejen till grillen eller till båten eller till när man ska ut och resa.
Så det prylar lite generellt för hemmet och fritiden.
Är det prylar, det här är en rolig extra grej att ha?
Eller är det dyrare teknologiska grejer?
Eller är det, det här har saknats på marknaden så det här måste in?
Eller är det mer en rolig grej?
Från början när vi startade hade vi mer att det kunde vara en rolig grej.
Men nu försöker vi hålla oss från att det bara är roligt.
Det kan hända att vi har gjort undantag men det är lätt att spåra ur.
Så det är ju funktionen, lösningen i produkten som vi är ute efter, att den löser ett problem.
Men att det blir lite roligt ibland är det problem som inte är så stora som vi löser.
Jag såg att ni hade en sån här som man ställde yoghurtpaketet upp och ner på för att yoghurten ska rinna ner.
Den borde jag köpa till mina svärföräldrar för de hugger alltid på mig.
De tycker jag slänger filen för tidigt.
Jag tycker ändå att jag skakar lite grann, men nej de blir alltid sura ändå.
Ja, jag ser det.
Det är också kul.
Svensk Innovation är en man i Sverige som har funnit och den produceras i Sverige.
Det är plast men den håller ju livet ut.
Så bra grej tycker jag.
Vi ska komma lite till timelineen på Smarta Saker och vi ska prata lite grann om dig också.
Men eftersom vi ändå är här, hur gör du för att inte balla ur i sortimentet?
Det måste vara rätt svårt att säga nej till någonting.
Ja det är det ju.
Fast vi har ju långa, långa, långa loggar med produkter som vi skulle vilja ta in som vi bara inte hinner.
Men vi är ett team som jobbar tillsammans och vi styr ju varandra och försöker hindra.
Ibland släpper man igenom något men oftast försöker vi vara överens och just inte bara ta in något för att man bara gillar den.
För då skulle sortimentet kunna bli hur brokigt som helst.
Jag hoppas vi håller oss till vår röda tråd men det är en liten utmaning.
Är det magkänsla eller finns det fyra kontrollfrågor man måste gå igenom för att bli godkänd?
Nej, inte nerskrivna kontrollfrågor.
Vi har väl generellt ganska lite för sånt.
Kärna magkänsla är ganska bra i det här fallet.
Det är funktionen och sen testar vi alla produkter som vi tar in.
Vi tar hem ett varuprov, använder produkten och ser att den funkar så som vi sen utlovar.
Och att det är bra kvalitet, bra material, att vi känner till ursprunget på produkten och hela den där grejen.
Det är ganska mycket handpåläggning innan en produkt kommer in i sortimentet.
Research och sådär kontakt med producenter.
Hur gör ni för de här produkterna?
Du pratar om era innovatörer eller era uppfinnare.
Är det de som tar fram alla produkter?
Kan du berätta om det upplägget lite grann?
Ja, jag är lite nyfiken på det.
Sortimentet är uppdelat på, det varierar ju men mellan 25 och 30 procent av sortimentet är svenska innovationer.
Men sen kan det ju vara innovationer generellt, vi har ju norska och finska och vad som helst.
Men sortimentet hittar vi över hela världen och köper in både på inte-container kanske, men med stor lastbåt från Kina till och med och produktion i Sverige.
Så det är väldigt högt och lågt.
Samarbetet med innovatörerna specifikt är ju oftast det är enskilda företagare som har tagit fram en produkt.
Sen kan den produkten leda till ett sortiment hos dem och bli ett bolag med lite större sortiment.
Men det varierar mellan att vi hittar dem och de hittar oss.
Sen är det också där det kan vara rätt mycket stöttning.
För det kan vara en person som startar sitt första bolag som just har tagit sig igenom hela den här enorma processen.
Att gå från idé till att producera och ha ett lager.
Där tar vi vid och kan vara säljkanalen.
Men det blir också rätt mycket hjälp om att räkna med oms och marginaler.
Hur man skriver en faktura, varför det är bra att ha ett riktigt bolag eller att det finns ett bankgiro.
Det är utbildningsnivå ibland också på de här starttillfället.
Sen är vi förhoppningsvis en språngbrädda och vill att de ska lyckas.
Vi har inga begränsningar eftersom vi inte får sälja hos någon annan.
När en sån produkt kommer in i sortimentet så går vårt lilla maskineri igång.
Ofta går det ut ett nyhetsmeddelande på Manjusdäsk så att andra kan uppmärksamma dig.
Det kommer in på sajten i fler kategorier.
Någon gång kommer nästan alla innovatörer att ha blivit profilerad som månadens innovatör då vi gör en längre intervju med dem och publicerar på våra sociala kanaler och LinkedIn.
Det är mycket som händer runt en enskild produkt.
Men hanterar ni ofta produktionen av den då efter att innovatörerna har gjort det?
Eller är det de som sköter det?
Nej, det är de som sköter det.
Som regel.
Och absolut för en ny produktion eller för det ska ju drivas av dem att producera och gå vidare och utveckla sin produkt.
Sen kan det ha hänt vid några tillfällen att en produkt, en innovatör, inte mäktar med sin enskilda produkt eller att det blir för mycket.
Efter några år så vill de bara sluta för att det tar för mycket energi för dem.
Då har vi ibland tagit över och sagt att då vill vi fortsätta producera din produkt, men med dig som innovatör förstås.
Vi tar liksom inte ifrån dem, utan under design och innovations kreddar vi alltid den här personen.
Så vi har några sådana och då producerar vi dem under smarta saker, och då får produkter leva kvar, vilket är himla kul.
Ja exakt.
Ni blir ju en liten plantskola om du är med på det jag menar.
Jag gissar att ni har lite namn i den branschen.
Att höra av dig till dem först och se om du kan komma in där.
Det måste vara en ganska vanlig väg in, gissar jag.
Det kan gärna bli mer.
Det är en del av det vi behöver sprida mer runt i innovationskretsar i Sverige.
Att den här möjligheten finns och att uppfinnare gärna får höra av sig med sin pryll till oss.
Man kan till och med få höra av sig och bolla idén innan man drar iväg hela produktionsapparaten.
Att bara höra vad vi tycker.
Nu har vi hållit på sen 2006, så ganska bra känsla för vad som funkar.
Och sen med respekt för att alla kunder tycker olika.
Vi har ju tagit in saker i resortementet så jag bara tycker vad är det här?
Och så visar det sig ju att kunderna älskar den.
Man ska inte gå bara på vad man själv tycker.
Jag kommer givetvis fråga, kan du ge något exempel på det där?
Jag vågar inte.
Jo det är klart du ska göra.
Det är inte den värsta frågan jag kommer ställa idag.
Vi har vattendelare, det finns en vattendelare.
Det finns en produkt som heter brelock som är ett smörlock med integrerad smörkniv.
Jag har sett den.
Den är helt horivel tycker jag.
Vi har sålt över 30-40 000 såna.
Hur många som helst.
Jag föredrar själv att diska smörkniven varje gång.
Men kunderna älskar den.
Min moste gjorde sådär fast med en vanlig kniv och så skar hon ett hål i locket.
Jag tyckte bara det var konstigt och äckligt.
Har hon en sån här?
Hon måste ju ha ett brel också.
Hon hade ju köpt en sån här.
Ja.
Jag kan inte fatta det.
Jag är på din linje där.
Men jag hade gett henne den i present och hon hade funnit så att den är fullt rimlig.
Det som är bra är att vi vet att vi tar in den här produkten i sortimentet och sen avgör kunderna om det blir en storsäljare, en jullvärmare eller bara någon som puttar på.
Vi hjälper till förstås att se till att det finns fina bilder, att det är bra produkttexter och att vi gör vad vi kan.
Men det blir ändå efterfrågan som styr om det blir en hit.
Ni jobbar inte någonting med olika pop-up-stores.
Jag tänker typ Design-torget borde ju ta in er inför varje jul och sånt där och bara här är deras hörn med alla nyheter som har kommit under året eller?
Ja det är precis.
Vi hade en pop-up-butik på NK för några år sedan, 2017.
Och då gick vi...
Ja det är många år sedan.
Jag tror det var 17.
Det är hemskt mycket jobb att ha det.
Och vårt fokus är e-handel.
Så jag ska aldrig säga aldrig.
Men jag tror inte...
Ja vi får se.
Men just nu, vi är en ganska liten organisation, så att ta ut den resursen ur organisationen, ja då väljer vi just nu att satsa på e-handel.
Och den butik vi har som är jätte jätteviktig.
Superviktig.
Ja jag tänker det.
Det är ganska...
Sådana här grejer är ganska roliga att gå och titta på.
Absolut.
Jag fattar att internet är en bättre marknad för det här.
Om man kan visa filmer, om man kan göra hela...
Här är 40 olika bilder som visar en i action och allt sånt där.
Men detta är ju sådant som är kul att gå och titta på.
När man går och strosar på stan liksom.
Det är det här...
Jag som följer med min flickvän och som har noll intresse av att kolla kläder hade ju hellre bara gått in i den här butiken.
Och bara hängt där en timme liksom.
Ja men låt oss växa lite till först då så kommer vi med fler butiker sen, jag lovar.
Det låter bra.
Ni får öppna er i Göteborg.
Yes.
Jag tänker, kan du inte ge oss en liten kort historia över smarta saker?
Det har ju funnits ganska länge och har varit liksom de avgörande punkterna under bolagets tillkommande framgång.
Ja, idén kom under mina föräldraledigheter.
Jag har själv en annan bakgrund med jobbat med redovisning, revision, bemanning av ekonomischefer och sånt där.
Jag har varit i hotellbranschen och trodde att det skulle vara min grej.
Men under föräldraledigheterna började hjärnan spårar i väg och entreprenörskap och att driva något eget kom som en stark känsla.
Jag tänkte att det skulle vara kul.
Jag och en kompis satt och pratade om hur vi var som barn, att man satt och vek hörnen i Hobbix-katalogen och Claes Ohlsson-katalogen och valde ut roliga saker.
Då växte den här idén fram med att samla de här roliga, smarta sakerna på ett ställe.
Välja ut dem och hjälpa kunder att hitta dem och att samarbeta med innovatörer och uppfinnare.
Det var kanske lite mer, vi sneglar ju på design-torret som gör samma saker med formgivare.
Ibland kanske vi krockar, men nu är det innovationen och den smarta lösningen som blir vårt fokus.
Det här var 2006 som bolaget bildades.
Det var fortfarande små barn hemma, sen var det nästan ettåring och nästan treåring och så ett nybildat bolag.
Lager i hallen och sen i något litet rum som vi inredde.
Det var en kul start och e-handeln var väldigt okänt.
Det fanns ju inte knappt, Facebook fanns inte kan man säga att det fanns, och iPhone kom 2009, så det var en hemsida.
Men det var kul, vi startade så och sprang med säckar till postkontoret och klämnade in och så där.
Men sen växte vi ur mitt hem, det började stinka kartong i hela lägenheten om familjen inte klagade.
Så har vi tagit oss fram från första lokalen på 70 kvadratmeter till att man flyttar och byter lokal och växer ur.
Fram till 2016, det är också jättelänge sedan, då kom vi till Sankt Ericsplan där bolaget har sin butik nu, och då hade vi e-handel, lager och butik i samma lokal och packade allting därifrån.
Så vi började också arbeta mer med vårt varumärke, hur vi såg ut, hur det visuella var.
Det var första steget och hur man uttrycker sig att vi ville sätta upp lite tydligare strategier kring det.
Sen 2017 hade vi den här pop-up-butiken på NK som sagt, då kände vi oss jättemaliga när huvudstaden kom och frågade om vi ville flytta in hos dem på NK.
Och där någonstans, om vi nu tar milstolparna, så fick vi inte plats i julkandeln.
Inleveranserna krockade med utleveranserna, vi hade hela butiken och lagret fullt med plastade pallar med paket som skulle ut.
När julen var slut började min jakt på en bättre, smartare lag och logistiklösning.
Det var helt centralt för att vi var tvungna att hålla nere sortimentet, trots att det var jul, för vi hade absolut ingenstans att lägga grejerna.
I mitt letande, i kontaktnätet och med lite...
I doktarbetet fick jag kontakt med Per Svärdström, som är vd för Apotea, och frågade honom vad skulle du gjort?
Hur hade du tänkt?
Det gäller som vi sitter i den här situationen.
Vi hade några möten och det slutade med att han och jag kom fram till att Apoteas, ägarbolag, gick in som delägare i smarta saker.
Vi fick flytta lager och logistik till Morgångåva, till deras logistikcenter.
Det är ett enormt fint samarbete med ett litet e-handelskluster där uppe i Morgångåva som ligger mellan Sala och Uppsala i Västmanland.
Där vi hjälper varandra mellan bolagen med e-handelsfrågor generellt och lager och logistik är centralt.
Det var en stor lättnad och har tagit bort den här flaskhalsen av att vi inte har plats för vårt lager och det är fantastiskt samarbete.
Okej, ska vi?
Får jag bara hoppa in där?
Ja gärna.
Vad tror du att han såg er ett bolag som gjorde honom intresserad av att gå in?
Han är ju en sann entreprenör själv, en fantastisk entreprenör och jag tror kanske att entreprenörskapet runtomkring att vi också stöttar andra som vill driva sina bolag och att vi får fråga honom, men jag tror att att driva bolaget på ett genomarbetat sätt och just det här entreprenörsfokuset skulle jag tro och svenska innovationer och hela idén skulle jag gissa.
Hade han ingen motivering när han sa att han ville investera, skrev han bara en liten lapp och lämnade över?
Sade han en fina BL-valgord.
Nej, nej, men det är väl också så med våra karaktärer som entreprenörer, det är väl oftast att man kör, man kör lite på magkänslan man kör för att det verkar bra.
Alla stannar inte alltid med att göra den stora analysen.
Men vi fann varandra där, så det var kul.
Ni kände inte varandra sen tidigare?
Nej, vi har en gemensam bekant.
Och du sökte inte kapital då, utan detta var någonting som bara växte fram i diskussionen?
Jag sökte en lösning för vår logistikfråga.
Ja, vad roligt.
Det är en jäkla kul väg till investering bara.
Jag tycker att det är en lite annorlunda väg, så det är ganska roligt.
Ja, verkligen.
Det är roligt.
Du sa att du var ensam som startade bolaget från början.
Vi var två som startade tillsammans.
Efter ett tag delade vi på oss, som det kan vara.
Sedan dess har Pär Svärdson eller Laulima som är ägarbolaget gått in.
Vi har haft en annan andel som nu har varit ägd av en passiv delägare, men den har nu Pelle Pettersson gått in och tagit hand om.
Sedan har vi också en del av medarbetarna i delägare.
Ja, det var roligt.
Jag hade ju med Pelle här i podden för några veckor sedan.
Det var ju så, jag hörde talas om det här bolaget lite grann.
För han pratade ju väldigt gott om det.
Jag kan förstå att man tar in honom som delägare för han...
Jag kände mig upplyft hela dagen efter det samtalet får jag nog nästan säga.
Det var ju en extrem force of nature som pratade.
Ja, visst är det.
Men ni har jobbat lite grann.
Varför tog du in, jag förstår Pär Svärttsson i hela logistiken.
Varför tog du in Pelle?
Nej men Pelle är ju drömmen.
Vi började prata...
Man kan ju inte ta in honom för att de är en god människa.
Nej men Pelle för den som inte vet är grundare för ett bolag som heter Omniarch som är e-handelsexperter och konsulter.
Så det var så vi fick kontakt första gången.
Varför jag uppverksammade dem över huvud taget var för att de börjar med att bjuda på en KPI-rapport på LinkedIn.
De har byggt bästa KPI-rapporten i Excel och så säger de varsågod den får ni ladda ner.
Det tyckte jag var så intressant att ha den inställningen till försäljning.
Jag laddade ner den, då får man förstås kontakt och sen började vi prata och sen har de gjort ett par jobb eller flera åt smarta saker, sådana här digitala genomlysningsarbeten.
Pelle har haft kontakt under flera år och han är en otroligt sund affärsman och det han inte kan om e-handel är knappt det här.
Så det är en fantastisk källa för allting, entreprenörskap, e-handelskunskap, kontakter, lösningar.
Jag tänker, du drev ju ändå bolaget i det blir drygt tio år, om jag förstår rätt, innan du tog in investerare.
Kändes det konstigt att lämna ifrån sig en del?
Nej, jag tycker att det viktigaste är samarbetena man har och vart man är på väg och hur man hjälper varandra.
Det har varit det som är fokus faktiskt.
Absolut, det låter väldigt sunt.
Det är bara svårt emotionellt att tackla det, men det är fullt sunt.
Så länge det är goda relationer så är det otroligt bra, för det är oftast ett plus ett mycket mer än två.
Det får man satsa på, men om det någonstans blir skav på vägen, då får man ju lösa det.
Det är roligare att driva saker tillsammans med andra än att försöka hålla på allting själv.
Man är ju extremt meningslös själv.
Det behövs många för att det ska bli bra.
Ni har ju produkter som...
Ganska många av era produkter ligger på ganska låga kostnader, mellan typ 40 till 300 spänn.
Jag vet inte vad er snittorder är, men det måste vara ganska svårt att få business i så låga ordervärden.
Kan du prata lite grann om det?
Jo precis, det måste förstås bli volym någonstans för att få ihop orderkalkylen.
Sen måste vi hålla i våra marginaler förstås.
Om man ser till helheten så jobbar vi otroligt mycket sedan några år tillbaka med hela varumärket.
Att försöka, att vi måste paketera vad vi erbjuder till kunden, vad är helhetslösningen och varför är vi en rolig destination.
All handpåläggning som vi har gjort, jag tror att kunderna känner när de kommer till sortimentet att det är noga utvalda grejer, inte bara ett hopp raffs.
Hela varumärkesbygget ger lite mer förtroende för att kunna sätta ett rimligt pris på produkten och inte bara bli stressad och köra kampanjer.
Det jag försöker säga är att mer värdet av att handla hos oss, det är grunden för att man kan hålla schyssta marginaler.
Ni gör inte heller Black Week och liknande, har jag för mig, att du har sagt.
Nej, det sitter lite ihop allt det här.
Vi vill vara ett bolag som beteer oss hållbart i den utsträckning vi kan.
Konsumtioner blir kanske inte alls hållbart överhuvudtaget, men om vi nu ska köpa produkter så ska de vara producerade på ett vettigt sätt.
De ska vara hållbara över tiden och hålla i kvalitet.
Det får absolut inte vara slit och släng och helst inte helt överlagda inköp.
Därför känner vi att Black Week är inget för oss att pressa kampanjpriser.
Du säger att ni behöver få upp volym.
Då gissar jag att ni lägger ett relativt stort arbete på få kunder.
De har varit hos er, då ska de komma tillbaka igen.
Det ska liksom bli, jag säger ju presenter, jag förstår att det inte är hela grejen, men varje gång man ska köpa en present, julklappspelet eller någon fyller år, då ska man nästan per automatik hamna hos er istället för oss.
Google borde ju vara bakgrundstanken.
Det är visionen, precis.
Hur jobbar ni med det och hur hanterar ni det?
Det är ett långsiktigt arbete att arbeta in varumärket och att bli top of mind när folk ska tänka.
Du förstår att man ska ha oss på nätinnan när man tänker på innovationer och presenter.
Fan, det bara slog mig nu.
Jag är ju sämst på födelsedagar och presenter.
Det här fattar jag kanske inte är en bra idé, men tänk om jag kunde bara sajna upp på er hemsida och ladda upp alla födelsedagar i min släkt.
Och så lägger jag upp kvinna 32, man 27, mamma.
Och så bara skickar ni ut en present två veckor innan.
Jag behöver inte ens, eller ni kan skicka tre val och så får jag bara klicka i.
Den vill jag.
Fan, jag hade älskat den tjänsten.
Då hade jag slut i att tänka resten av mitt liv.
Det är ju jättebra idéer.
Ska ni snicka ihop en sådan?
Då pratar jag upp oss om lektråd.
Det är bara jag som använder den sen.
Jag tror också att det är ett behov som kunder har att få snabb hjälp.
För är det något vi inte har så är det tid.
Då kanske vi kan vara behjälpliga där.
Vi har de här kategorierna för kvinna 30-40.
Då kan man gå in och titta i den presentkategorin och säga att här hittar jag bra grejer.
Vi har till och med byggt en presentgenerator.
Den får du kolla på sen.
Den är mer styrd på vilka intressen du har.
Om du är en outdoor-människa eller en hemma-mysare.
Lite rolig.
Jag gillar det, vad smart.
Det tog hjälp av chackepeterna när vi skulle hitta på de här karaktärerna som vi byggt på.
Åh fan vad nice.
Svegårdsentusiaster och vad det nu är för någonting.
Det är ju faktiskt ganska roligt också.
Men är det det som är, återigen då, jag gissar som sagt att ni behöver bli en destination eller någonstans där man går in och kikar eftersom kategorierna på något sätt blir så pass spretiga.
Det blir alltid svårt att synas på topp på lökhackare blir väldigt svårt.
Det är ju mycket lättare på er kategori då.
Men finns det något mer än att nisha sig mot presenter eller födelsedagar eller gör ni på något annat sätt för att folk ska komma tillbaka rent praktiskt?
För att de ska komma tillbaka så använder vi vårt CRM förstås och har automationer som vi jobbar med.
Men det är ju för de som prenumererar på ett nyhetsbrev så kan man hälsa dem välkomna och sen återkomma med ett brevflöde för att vinna tillbaka dem till sitt andra och tredje köp.
Men vi är ju inte annorlunda från någon annan, vi är otroligt styrda av vad folk söker.
Så både vårt SEO och SCM är jätteviktigt.
Googlesöket är superviktigt, men för att väcka nyfikenhet och intresse så får vi använda Meta.
Det är ju roligt för här kan man använda mycket mer bildmaterial och rörligt och så.
Någonstans där.
Det är ju otroligt komplexa utmanande framför allt för oss som vill marknadsföra produkter som de inte visste att de behövde.
För det söker man ju inte på.
Vi rattar på det här hela tiden.
Hur man kan både jobba uppe i tunnel och sen försöka veva in dem i sitt exakta behov när de söker på någonting.
Men det är svårt.
Hur jobbar ni med SCO och SCM?
Vad är det ni driver in folk till?
Finns det första gångsprodukter som folk ofta köper?
Det måste vara jättesvårt när ni har så brett sortiment.
SCO är ju, dels har vi stor kraft av att sidan har funnits länge till att börja med.
Och att det finns stark länkkraft sen gammalt.
Sen har vi hela tiden producerat nya produkttexter, nya url'er så att vi bygger ut sidan mer och mer.
Och sen optimerar vi förstås alla produktsidor och alla kategorisidor.
Och kategorisidorna är ju det bredaste söket och kanske mest tacksamma eller vad man ska säga att optimera.
Sen har vi också en blogg som vi använder mycket för att få in sök på eller till.
Så det är ett evigt tillande förstås och uppdaterande och underhåll.
Men vad är era starka kategorier?
Vad är det man hittar er på?
Alltså presentkategorierna är jättestarka, det gör de förstås.
Och sen generellt, det som människor har stort intresse av, kök, hem, städ, tvätt, som berör många.
Men presenter är väldigt roligt, att vi för ett par år fick det svenska SCO-priset i kategorin presenter.
Det är sånt som vi tycker är superkul.
Jag förstår det.
Nu kommer det låta som att jag är kritisk, och det är jag inte, jag är bara nyfiken.
Ni har ju inget eget lager, utan man kan ju säga att ni har ett tredjebortslager.
Nej, det kan man inte säga.
Man kan absolut inte säga det.
Vi har ett helt eget lager.
Allt som du ser på hemsidan har vi köpt hem och har i lager.
Men är det ni inte anställda som packar, utan ni köper tjänsten?
Ni har anställda som packar?
Absolut.
Okej, okej, okej.
Alla bolaget är anställda i respektive bolag.
Det är också en grej att vi vill lagerhålla och veta att vi har kontroll över hela logistiken och att när kunderna har lagt sin order då bara tar timmar senare så är paketet packat och på väg.
Så, ja.
Okej, jag fattar.
Så det är egentligen bara ytan ni har och avtalen med Morgon gåvan, men det är ni som driver själva operationen.
Ja, vi driver i vårt hus.
För nu är det flera där uppe så vi jobbar tillsammans med Vidfors och Babyland och Delitea, bland annat.
Och vi samarbetar då med packmaskiner och spedition och har gemensam lagerchef och sånt där.
Sen så just de som packar smarta sakerspaket i våra stjärnor.
Och sen så hjälper vi varandra.
När någon har mycket på sin packstation så hjälper vi varandra att gå emellan och se till att alla får ut alla paket.
Okej, vad spännande.
Okej, blir det aldrig en motsättningskonflikt?
Mötspaket är viktigast.
Ja, exakt.
Under julmånader måste det bli lite halvhopplöst.
Då behöver alla hjälp.
Men sen åker vi upp från kontoret, så vi åker upp alla, hjälper till och packar.
Det är plattar i mattan för alla, det är bara att köra.
Det jag tänkte belysa var att om jag kollade rätt så hade ni ungefär 20 anställda.
Jag trodde inte ni hade lager, så då tänkte jag att det är ganska många anställda.
Då undrar jag vad alla de här människorna gör.
Det undrar jag lite fortfarande.
Vad är fördelningen på vad folk sysslar med oss?
Vi är väl kanske inte riktigt så många om man tittar såhär.
Det är tre på lagret i Morgåva.
Sen har vi lyckats anställa väldigt många människor som är färdiga ålder.
Det här året har vi fyra första underbara smarta små barnen födts.
Fyra på en gång under tolv månader, jättekul.
Just nu är det tre föräldralediga.
Har du gått en kurs i att man ska prata positivt för att när du säger de på lagret säger du stjärnorna på lagret, sen säger du underbara smarta barn som har födts här.
Det är ju så, de är ju svinduktiga uppe Linda, Oliver och Henrik.
Det är ju de som gör nästan, utan dem får kunderna inga paket.
Jag tycker att det viktigaste vi har på smarta saker är våra medarbetare.
Det är utan fekan.
Absolut, men de behöver ju inte reproducera sig så snabbt.
Vi har ju fem barn på två år här på vårat lager.
Jag har sagt åt dem nu att ni får sluta med detta.
Ni är fyra personer, ni kan inte ta det lugnt nu.
Skaffa en hobby eller något.
Ja, skaffa en hobby.
Det är jättekul.
Det är både kul och utmanande förstås.
Men, men, ja, vad ska jag säga?
De är två välkomna, de här sötarna.
Vad gör kinalen?
Vad är uppdelningen på folks jobb?
Ja, och sen har vi två också stjärnor.
Butiksmedarbetare som är ansvariga för butiken, Alice och Matilda.
Och på kontoret så är vi nio.
Som jobbar med...
Amanda är ansvarig för inköp och redovisning.
Och så är det jag.
Och sen har vi en e-commerce manager.
Och så är det två på kundtjänst.
Och en...
Sebastian som är fotograf och grafiker.
Och så har vi David som kör SEO och alla produkttexter.
Och Lisa som gör all kommunikation.
I övrigt.
Har fått med alla, jag tror det.
Fan det låter logiskt när du säger det så där.
Jag bara funderar på vem som gör de där grejerna hos oss.
Vi kanske inte gör de grejerna bara, vi bara hoppar över rätt mycket.
Vad är din stora punkt?
Vad är det du sysslar mest med?
Jag sysslar mycket med, det blir en del runt, det verkar kanske vara inblandade det mesta, och den digitala marknadsföringen sköter ju Erik, vår e-comm-manager, hemskt mycket tillsammans med Lisa och vår byrå Viva.
För mig är det ju att jag är resurs för alla medarbetare förstås.
Jag gör faktiskt boksluten och ingår i resortimentsteamet.
Overall planering och koll på balansen i bolaget.
Sen ser vi på den här svenska och EU-marknaden, vi styrer av otroligt mycket direktiv, lagar och grejer som vi måste följa.
Det ska rapporteras, producenten får rapportera förpackningar, du vet, det är otroligt mycket, det hamnar på mig i sådana här administrationer.
Men sen kan jag inte låta bli att starta projekt, det är vi flera som gör här.
Det känns som en motsättning här i att du har den här revisor, personligheten och den kreativa sidan.
Tycker du själv att det är en weird motsättning?
Jag vet inte hur kreativ jag är, men...
Energisk då.
Min tanke är att revisorer ska vara sura.
Vet du, jag kanske inte passade så bra som revisor.
Jag kanske inte gjorde det så många år heller.
Det är jättebra att ha koll på siffrorna, det är jag jätteglad att jag har, att redovisningen, att jag fattar den.
Min främsta styrka är väl just att driva saker och att hitta lösningar på allt som uppstår när man driver ett bolag, det tror jag.
Och att liksom vara kompassen framåt, vart är vi på väg?
Vad har varit knepigast där?
Nu är ni ändå, jag tänker att någonstans upp till 8-10 pers så har man koll på alla och man känner alla ganska tajt.
20 pers, eller säg att ni skulle vara 18 eller 17 eller vad ni vill säga, då blir det ju ändå lite grupperingar, det blir en annan sorts arbetsplats och sådär.
Ni har varit med väldigt länge, vad har varit svårast som ledare eller chef?
Vi är inte riktigt där än, att vi är så många, utan jag tror att vi fortfarande har, eller vi har ju fortfarande den här platta organisationen utan mellan chefer och...
Alltså, det jag är övertygad om, det är att det viktigaste i det här, det är att göra bra rekryteringar.
Att man rekryterar självständiga ansvarstagande, nyfikna medarbetare som tycker om att både jobba självständigt och i team.
Det som är viktigt här på den här arbetsplatsen är att man känner sig trygg och att man kan dela med sig och att man tar hjälp när man behöver hjälp.
Än så länge så är vi tillräckligt få för att slippa ha mellanlager och jag tror, som du är inne på, att det kommer bli en annan sorts organisation när vi måste gruppera.
Men vi grupperar oss utifrån vilken uppgift det är som ska lösas.
Men vad har varit svårast för dig under de här åren som ledare?
När ligger du vaken på natten?
Ja, du menar så.
Från början var det ju av utmattning när man gjorde allt själv.
Och hade småbarn samtidigt.
Men sen så nu är det ju mer att hastigheten i förändringen ökar, som takten när allting förändras, och komplexiteten blir ju större och större i att driva e-handel.
Det är kanske komplexiteten i vårt samhälle överhuvudtaget.
Och att inte tappa någon av trådarna av det som är viktigt.
Men efter de här enorma tillväxtåren 2021-2022 så gjorde vi som alla andra, hade byggt för stort lager, hade för dålig likviditet.
Nu upptäckte vi det och satte fart på det ganska tidigt.
Men det är sådant som man ligger vaken av.
Bara oj balansen här, hur ska jag rädda det här?
Jag vill inte dra ner på hastigheten på någonting.
Men vi styrde upp det.
Och sänkte lagret, fick uppliggning för likviditeten.
Jag tänkte bara följa upp den lite där.
För ni har ju, visst har ni vunnit i EGACEL två gånger.
Eller vunnit, men ni har fått en utmärkelse ändå.
Ni har ju haft en ganska fin tillväxt och haft, vad ska man säga då, ett väldigt sunt bolag liksom.
Och sen så nämner du ju den här perioden som du nämner, ni har stagnerat lite grann under några år.
Högst troligen ganska tuffa år.
Och dessutom fattar ju du siffror, för vissa entreprenörer är det lite lättare att bara blunda för siffrorna, och så kör man bara på lite grann.
Men högst troligen fattar du när det står illa till med mycket lager och liknande, vad det faktiskt innebär i komplikation.
Hur har du hanterat tankarna där och hur tänker du framåt utifrån den situationen?
Har du ändrat synsätt på något sätt?
Utifrån som balans och lager ligger vi till?
Jag gissar att du hade några år när det rullade på på ett visst sätt och då tänker man att det här är vår affärsmodell, så här jobbar jag nu, det här är rätt sätt att jobba.
Sen kommer corona, sen kommer lågkonjunktur och då helt plötsligt blir det så här, fan, var det där riktigt rätt sätt?
Ja det kanske var rätt sätt, bara det här var några tuffa år.
Fortsätter du på samma sätt nu som du gjorde innan corona?
Eller har du justerat lite grann?
Ja men du verkligen, innen på något, i corona så hade vi en mer automatisk efterfrågan.
Och sen som du säger så kom räntor och höga energipriser och allting.
Och det kändes ju då som att, ja men det här vet vi går över.
Men sen för ett år sedan så togs det här vid av att Temu döpt upp.
Och då tänkte vi först att det är väl som wish att det går över, men sen insåg vi att det gör det ju inte, det går inte över.
I alla fall inte på kort sikt.
Sen som det går att EU reglera bort eller minska skadan och påverkan, det får vi se.
Men där står vi ju nu, så nu måste vi anpassa oss till en annan konkurrenssituation som tyvärr är skev.
Men dess skeva är vi för lite spelare att rås på, vi kan försöka höja rösten och prata om det.
Att konsumenter ska ta ansvar för vilka inköp man gör, att man faktiskt har koll på de grejerna.
Att våra organisationer, Svensk Handel gör ett fantastiskt jobb, men de kan inte göra allt det här själva.
Konkurrenssituationen med Temur som spelare är inte okej.
Men vi kan bara fortsätta fokusera på att det vi gör, ska bli göra ännu bättre.
Det går jättemycket energi till det och pengar.
Det kostar pengar att försöka vara synlig.
Hela Google-miljön har ju förändrats.
CPC-priserna drar iväg som bara tusan.
Det handlar bara om att anpassa sig och att jobba hårt på att stärka sitt varumärke, så att de som vet, de vet och då ska de välja oss.
Ja, men gör ni mer av det som ni har gjort tidigare, eller har ni förändrat affärsidéen och modellen nu sen Temur kom till exempel?
Nej, vi gör nog mer av det som vi gjorde tidigare och försöker vara tydligare med vad vi står för.
Det som är roligare med Smartma Saker är att affärsidéen, grundidéen om att samla ett smart sortiment, den har vi inte ändrat en enda gång sen 2006.
Den är exakt den samma och strategin har alltid varit att bara göra det, inte börja producera egentligen, eller innovation.
Men hela miljön runtomkring är det som ändras.
Så det vi måste vara duktiga på är att hänga med i utvecklingen, vara uppdaterade och inte reagera för sent, utan reagera för tidigt.
På förändringarna.
Ja, det är tufft, vi har fått en oskyst konkurrens, men vi måste bara anpassa oss.
Nu kanske det blir en konstig formelé, jag har inte tänkt igenom denna, men när du pratar om temet till exempel, då pratar man ju ofta om att det är ohållbart, eller man pumpar liksom ut dåliga saker helt enkelt.
Alltså, antingen giftiga eller dålig kvalitet, eller bara dåliga arbetsvillkor, det är ofta det man sätter på den sidan då.
Det man per automatik börjar tänka på själv då är att, då gör vi mer hållbarhet, eller vi gör mer god kvalitet, eller finns det en risk i att man nästan pushar för långt åt det hållet, och att det nästan blir det argumentet som man säljer till kunden, istället för här är en sida med roliga, smarta saker.
För att kunderna är ju inte så eftertänksamma.
Vi kan ju låtsas att vi tar goda beslut hela tiden, men det gör vi inte, utan folk handlar i dåliga grejer.
Hur tänker man själv kring den frågan?
Det är en bra fråga verkligen, och det gäller ju att det inte drar er för långt till den sidan heller.
Jag går inte till smarta saker för att köpa en hållbar grej, jag går ju dit för att jag vill ha en skön present som jag litar på.
Ja men precis.
Men det är också vad vi har för filosofi kring att driva ett företag, så den har vi kanske inte ändrat så mycket, utan vi är fortfarande så att vi gör faktiskt samma sak.
Vi köper hållbara saker eller har hög kvalitet, allt det här.
Men det vi kanske måste göra bättre är att tala om det.
Jag tror att där har vi fortfarande något kvar att göra.
Och upplysa kunden om att snabba leveranser blir lagra i Sverige.
Men är man inte intresserad av de här frågorna då spelar det ingen roll.
Då kommer man ju ändå att handla på dropshipping-sajter utan kontroll.
Vi ska inte fasta i det här men det som jag sörjer är ju att konsumenter inte har fått tillräcklig upplysning om att det faktiskt är jättefarliga produkter man köper ibland.
Tänk dig att du köper en plastprodukt med för höga cadmium eller blyhalter eller talater och så ger du det till ditt barn.
Och effekten av det ser vi inte nu.
Det är ju sen när det påverkar reproduktion och man kan få cancer och allt sånt.
Det är varför vi borde skydda våra konsumenter från det.
Och det är farligt på riktigt.
Det är som du säger, vi hade kunnat snacka vidare det där, men vi ska inte fastna i det.
Det sa vi dessutom innan så jag hoppar vidare.
Vi släpper det nu.
Du har ju, vad blir det, 18 år då om jag räknar rätt?
Oj, oj, oj.
Det blir liksom större delen av ditt arbetande liv, eller vuxna liv, eller vad man ska säga.
Hade du kunnat vara anställd, kan du inte jobba med detta?
Jag vet inte.
Jag har inte tänkt på det faktiskt riktigt.
Allt är väl möjligt, men så länge, jag tycker att driva det här bolaget och utveckla det och se vart det kan ta vägen är väldigt roligt.
Att ha möjligheten att styra och fatta beslut själv, vi har otroligt korta beslutsvägar här, det kommer upp en idé, vi säger att det är lite kul, vi kör ofta med KBK, kör bara kör.
Vi testar nya idéer, är de bra så utvecklar vi dem, är de dåliga så gör vi inte om dem.
Det här sättet att driva bolag och jobba på tycker jag är jättekul.
Har du nån tanke kring det här är vad jag vill göra med bolaget, eller jobbar du redan på det sättet som du vill och vill bara hålla det så länge det bara går?
Jag skulle absolut vilja ha upp tillväxt och lönsamhet och ta större andelar och växa på alla de marknader som vi finns på.
Vi finns ju i Danmark, Finland, Norge också och har en EU-site på engelska.
Så det finns otroligt mycket kul kvar att göra.
Förutom svenska innovationer så finns det innovationer i alla länder i Europa.
En av storsäljaren är en norsk innovation.
Du ser ut som att du vill veta vad det är.
Det är klart jag vill veta vad det är.
Det är en sop pink som heter Frank som komprimerar soporna.
Ah okej, nice, jag gillar det.
Du sätter i en vanlig soppåse och så är locket så att du kan trycka ihop och så trycker du ihop och trycker ihop.
Tänk att allt plastskräp du samlar in hemma.
Jag hade behövt det när vi hade blöjor på båda banorna hemma.
För det var helt hopplöst att få plast i det.
Jättesmart är det, norsk innovation.
Just kring innovationer och det sortimentet finns det ju jättemycket att göra.
Man skulle kunna ha ett roligt innovationspris.
Man skulle kunna samla det här som är unikt och lyfta upp det.
Så att vi kan bara fortsätta på samma spår och bara utvecklas.
Jag ser ju att du blir glad när du pratar om det.
Det ser ju inte alla är men det hör man väl på rösten.
Men är det det som är det roligaste med dagen?
Är det när det är någon som skriver till mig att jag har en ny grej?
Det kan vara roligt, superroligt.
Sen är det vårt arbete på kontoret och i bolaget och alla medarbetare, det vi gör tillsammans.
Det är jätteroligt.
Det är jätteroligt att läsa våra Trustpilot om dömen och vad kunderna skriver.
Det är flera saker.
Sen följer vi statistiken på alla håll och kanter.
Alltid är det någon kopi som pikar så det är kul.
Du nämnde lite här den internationella delen.
Jag gissar att ni är rätt Sverige-tunga men jag vet ju inte.
Jo, men det stämmer.
Ungefär 60% av omsättningen ligger i Sverige på e-handeln.
Och sen tillkommer butiken som har ungefär 10% av omsättningen.
Och resten är Norge, Danmark, Finland.
Hur länge sen har ni öppnade upp i något annat land?
Norge var 2018, och Finland, Danmark 2021 tror jag.
Vad är det som gör det svårt att komma in på en ny marknad?
Precis samma som i Sverige.
När man inte har en enorm marknadsföringsbudget så blir det Google-söket.
Nu är vi beroende av att det är svårare där eftersom priserna har gått upp.
Generellt är det lite smala sökord vi rör oss på.
Men vi gör vad vi kan för att lokala passarsidan ska vara perfekt översatt till det lokala språket med lokala frakt-
och betalsätt.
Vi har en native kundtjänst, så man får prata finska på finska kundtjänst och norska och danska för sina marknader.
Jaha okej, bra jobbat.
Där jobbar vi med ett bolag som heter Makes You Local.
Så det är en superbra, ytterligare bra samarbete.
Jag känner att du har fan droppat alla de stora namnen här nu.
Vi har Omnyards, vi har Viva Media och vi har Makes You Local.
De borde ju lyfta fram dig som ambassadör här.
Du, Arash, får väl bjuda in dig till vd-podden här före eller senare.
Ja, jag hälsar honom det.
Det är roligt, jag tycker att när man har bra samarbeten ska man lyfta dem, verkligen.
Och jag tycker ju att Omnyards lyfter oss, vi hjälps åt rätt bra där och så finns sådana där profiler med oss som case på de där sajterna, det gör det faktiskt.
Ella, vi hann på ungefär en timme.
Det tycker jag, vi klonkar in på nästan exakt en timme.
Jag är oerhört stolt över att vi lyckades playa av detta.
Då ska vi säga att jag kopplade helt bort alla frågor om dig som privatperson.
Så vill man veta det, då får man väl kontakta dig.
Ja, jag finns på LinkedIn, det var att höra om sig.
Exakt, jag är jättetacksam för att du tog dig tid.
Det var supertevligt att prata med dig, jag tycker ju att det var ett bra samtal.
Och som sagt, ser ni några roliga innovationer eller smarta prylar därute, så kontakta oss, skicka till Info eller till Ella Smarta Saker eller Ramanda.
Gå bra också.
Och tipsa oss om smarta prylar, sådant som ni har hittat, det kan vara utomlands eller...
Jättebra, gör det.
Ännu roligare med innovatörer som vill höra om sig.
Fan, det bara slog mig nu.
Jag är ju sämst på födelsedagar och presenter.